I'm hope coat and they grew up in New
York and I'm back in New York again
having lived in England in around the
world
just recently Brooklyn what I witnessed
it was post 59 was all the tens of
thousands of Tibetan refugees at calm
and dojin was one of the most vibrant
and in a way unstable places it was very
very interesting to me sickened was very
different in feeling from Darjeeling
that darjeeling was this great
reverent lands coming in and a sense of
a contest that there was there were
different groups going toe-to-toe seek
him felt hugely harmonious that there
was an enormous sense of their their
nests a sense of order not in a
repressive way of sense of of coherence
is a better word than order and a sense
of development done in a careful way
small many Hydra projects as you cross
the border
um as seeking goes up like an elevator
from sea level with its border with
India out to 28,000 800 feet out there
to have every different flora fauna
changing every 10 our yards are no I
didn't think I had a mandate to have a
supreme position in education nor know
much it was never anything I'd studied I
studied history of Asian culture but not
teaching it was having kids and you
really
or did I really wanted my own children
to learn from where they were and not
from the outside in and as in many Asian
places at the time or in fact much of
the world ah the education tended to be
all British Indian very much based on
Victorian outside in Graham the child
from the furthest room I wanted my
children to grow make plants what was
nothing about sicken it was not a
society run by experts now I know NGOs
can do such great good and sometimes I'm
really envious when I hear about NGOs
and Nepal Bhutan today there we have
some insecure but there are more other
places but what was good about not
having quote experts or was did he
ground up all the teachers were going
way out of the box
great gran oral histories to get the
material the schoolchildren the seniors
were helping us tape record massive oral
histories and to put into the books into
the curriculum and all they also for the
first time began doing in different
language streams to make sure that each
language stream read what the other
children were reading there were
translations because in the past
textbooks had drawn the lecture children
had been reading Christian books and
Nepali speaking children books from
Nepal which in turn flowed from India
which in turn flowed from England or
over stamped with illustrations from
British train to Indian Monkey to Nepal
you know basketry whatever and Tibetan
said being written really particularly
Tibetan children amount of motor
tsukimiya so it was very thrilling
people from all over and many Indian
educators some of their supreme models
the head of the University Grants
Commission wanted after retirement to
come and work in Sikkim because they
were so pleased that here is the place
small enough that you could see effect
to something good happening because
India is such fantastic work they're
doing so many areas but the problems are
so big demography is so big that they
get swallowed up you can't really see
the sustained happenings the D are we
started the textbook things are about 67
68 i remembers pregnant at the turn so
they weren't published are until towards
about 1970 and it was difficult are
seeking books continued after the on an
edition but they began to change them
and take out different things so they
didn't less do much longer and the head
of the wonderful teacher Rosabelle ray
who was the great force behind this i
was a began to retire and it was a shift
of ground but in some ways he continued
because they were copied by Himachal
Pradesh and by Bhutan so I was there and
by New York for example which makes me
really proud I haven't been back since
the since I left in 1973 in New York
where we rented my house was like a
mattress shop full of sick æneas who are
like family would come from their
colleges wherever and with get together
also special
times of trouble that sometimes take off
a semester see what they could do down
and we're friends in a deeper way than
we could've been in sickle so I am I
have to see fairly up-to-the-minute and
what is happening and again because it
really matters to me and and like any
little desperate group see thing with
new news and and enough being part of
that it's very much I've internalized
cqms my home you
you